hey everybody welcome back to Planet zoo
I know it's been a while since my last
standalone habitat build which to be
honest I only started doing those back
in the beta days I think because I
didn't have enough time to really build
a full zoo but now this is just kind of
what I think I'm gonna be doing for the
time being because my computer doesn't
seem to be able to handle bigger parks
and I just like doing these standalone
habitat builds it really allows me to
focus on something specifically but I
haven't done many of these recently
really the only planet Zoo videos that I
have made are koala zoo ones so you
might be wondering why I wanted to get
back into this at this point and
honestly it's mostly because the South
American DLC as well as a free update to
the game aren't dropping which as this
video comes out should be about today if
my timing is right so this means that we
have a lot of new pieces to play with
and for me even though I'm not building
anything South American in this episode
I'm still gonna be you know playing with
the pieces a bit and seeing what we can
do and if you're wondering why I'm not
actually building something that is
South American because I'm getting very
off-topic probably here and doing
something completely different than
other youtubers are doing well for one I
guess it is kind of good to not do the
same thing that everybody else is doing
but to be totally honest I just really
really wanted to build some Swahili
architecture and just try my hand at a
very particular style that I've always
wanted to try and that especially now
with the South American pieces I figured
would be a really really funny concept
so you're gonna see a bit of that in a
few minutes after I'm done doing all of
this part work a shout out to Mike by
the way who I believe was the person who
taught me this trick of making gentle
perfectly slopes straight paths as you
just told me do for those two bridges
unfortunately this very first part of
the video like only this first part
where I do the path work was done before
I got my early access youtuber special
code to play the DLC so at that point I
didn't have the fine-tuned path sort of
mechanics that come with the new update
of the game but and I believe this is
included in the free update
along with the glass pieces the path
system has been improved and now you can
make much more gentle slopes more easily
and naturally so that's really awesome
so it kind of means that what I just did
that trick with the flat roof pieces and
trying to align my parts with them who
is kind of unnecessary but hey shout out
to Mike anyway for showing me that trick
that was a really the og way to get
gentle slopes in parts until now the new
days with this DLC and the free updates
actually where you can finally much more
easily get some smoother sloped paths
which is really awesome I know that the
the path system has always been one of
the biggest main gripes that people have
with this game and planet coaster as
well and honestly the same goes for me
the path system is just one of my
biggest problems with this game overall
it's just something that apparently I've
been told a few times is really
difficult to overcome because it's kind
of hard baked into the engine and the
way that it works with the the voxel
terrain but at least with these
improvements in slopes it'll be a bit
easier to make more smooth flowing paths
so that's really awesome
so whatever agony you just told me go
through it's not entirely necessary
anymore and for this part of this part
honestly I couldn't be bothered anymore
so I just decided to make this a purely
aesthetic path that's there for a
suspense of disbelief that this part is
going to be a TA comply ball and it's
you know it's it's gonna allow for
people in wheelchairs or other
disabilities to actually dance into the
habitat as well so I wanted to you know
get that out of the way before I moved
into anything else and this has also
been a bit of a struggle with quality I
think recently because well mike has
built a bunch of really amazing
beautiful areas which are very hard to
access by wheelchair so I'm gonna try my
best to not forget about them in this
build and include all kinds very gentle
ramps which should hopefully be fine I
think technically this ramp is slightly
steeper than what is allowed by a TA
measurements I don't actually know about
European standards because I'm really
only thinking about the American
Disabilities Act here going a bit off
topic also but yeah just just trying to
look out for my you know non able-bodied
people as well right so it's gonna be
interesting because I wanted to raise
the general surrounding of the lion
habitats so that you look down into it
and there's also a natural kind of cliff
between the path and the habitat itself
so that there's not much blocking the
view and then it doesn't really feel
like you know the animals are caged in
some kind of man-made structure but
rather it flows smoothly into a natural
landscape but in order to do that of
course I had to connect the past to some
other level as well so I just decided to
have some part work shenanigans at the
start of this build which for me is also
kind of unusual because normally I start
off with buildings and just kind of go
from there because they're more or less
my my favorite thing to work on but for
this build I just wanted to get a little
bit of context and first see how
everything would work and how the
buildings would be placed and only after
that figure out my sight lines and how
the whole structure is going to come
together and I'm very glad I did this
because I recorded this before I got my
early access copy of the DLC and the
free update of the game so once I did
get it I could move straight into
building buildings and testing some of
the new pieces which to be honest I
won't be doing that much because I can
still fall back on a lot of the old
pieces as well but I would not have been
able to make what I'm making in this
video without the the new pieces mostly
because the South American pieces have
some really great stone items that are
super useful for this theme as well so
let's get it over with
and actually get started with building
and this is one of my my first
discoveries that I sort of made when I
opened the DLC looks around four pieces
and you know try to see these pieces are
made for South Americans have both
structures but what else can we also use
these for like how versatile are these
pieces because those are for me at least
my main questions I like following the
themes that the game
gives sometimes but more than that I
just like taking the pieces and putting
them to different uses and trying to see
how versatile they are using them in all
kinds of context so that's that was kind
of my goal here as well and I love these
temple floor pieces because it's just
the kind of recoverable stone texture
that I think the game was kind of
missing and in general I'm really glad
actually that this pack has a lot of
recoverable pieces stone textures as
well because so far planet shoe has been
following an approach where natural
items as in items that have some kind of
natural texture that doesn't change
orange recolor ball and the only
recoverable items are the ones that
realistically in a real life scenario
would be recoverable either because
they're painted or because there is
something that could be baked in
different colors and I'm really glad
that we now have more pieces that are
recoverable that actually have more
natural stone textures as well because
it's just something that allows you to
have more variety in your builds like
I'm going to use some stone pieces
throughout this facade here and in
different places I want to use slightly
different colors so that there's just a
bit more variety which is yeah I'm just
really glad that made its way into the
game now to actually talk about the
architecture I think what started this
off in my head was maybe over a year ago
already because back at that point a
twitter user called Igbo excellence
posted a big thread on twitter
explaining all the the great things that
african architecture has achieved and
that it's very underrated which by the
way I totally agree that was a really
really cool tweet that I think opened up
a lot of people's eyes on African
architecture which tends to be quite
underlooked
compared to other regions in the world
and he just provided all kinds of
examples from different countries and
cultural backgrounds that was really
cool and from this I think it was that I
found a picture of lamu in Kenya where
there is a very specific type of Swahili
architecture which almost blends some
influences of Middle Eastern
architecture as well because it's right
on the same coast and used to be part
very similar trade routes and it's just
super awesome I think that's where my
inspiration came from I ended up
following him on Twitter as well but
then after posting about architecture he
just started being horny on his main and
I wasn't really on Twitter looking for
pictures of women I'm really there only
to look at pictures of buildings of
course so I had to unfollow sadly but
still shout out to a crow for making him
really amazing through the threat and
getting a lot of people inspired when it
comes to African high potential because
there's some really cool stuff out there
so in general what this kind of Swahili
architecture looks like is a lot of
whites very yeah straight walls with not
even that much detail but just a
wonderful like natural textures with
also mangrove wouldn't support
structures and details which is really
cool so I love the context or the
contest between this this white simple
wall textures and then the very sparse
wooden detailing and supports on these
buildings and sometimes also some
thatched roofs which I was actually
looking into recently are apparently
called makuu tea I am probably
mispronouncing literally everything I'm
saying in this video but yeah it's just
a really cool simple style that doesn't
take too many items if you're looking at
planets do for instance and how you
could build it in this game but it very
quickly comes together in a really
beautiful picture it's also really cool
because you can play a lot with depth
because the the textures and detailing
is so simple and pretty laid back that
really the interesting thing to play
with is composition and depth in some of
your buildings I think so that's also
what I'm doing here a lot you barely
find any straight pieces or boxy parts
of this building everything's kind of
set back from each other or overhanging
something else and placed at a slightly
different angle which altogether creates
this really interesting sort of Rhapsody
of simple parts of the building I've
also found that a lot of these buildings
tend to have
vertical but also horizontal support
beams made out of mangrove wood which I
wanted to bring back into this building
as well with the porch for instance
which is raised on the left side there
kind of like a trellis almost and of
course all of the little windows as well
now I'm making this building out of the
the plaster pieces because they're just
so versatile I still love them so much
and in that sense the way that I'm
working this is kind of inspired by
Teleco which is an old planet coaster
project bifida bear and at foe TV which
isn't even finished as I'm speaking it's
something that's been going for years
but it uses very similar architecture
and back then they used Windows that the
backside of windows in planet coaster to
make these walls obviously we have the
plaster pieces nowadays which is much
easier and much less heavy on your
computer but the same kind of way of
working still stands very few of the
walls are actually made out of wall
pieces everything is made out of plaster
pieces just because it allows for that
versatility of creating walls that are
maybe smaller than the in-game wall
pieces are or making holes here in there
for the windows it's just super simple
you don't see too much detail on it but
at the same time it looks more organic I
think then you know if you make
everything out of just simple walls and
select details on top of that so moving
on from that I did want to add a section
where this building actually has some
kind of function
now of course I'm building this as a
separate habitat but within my suspense
of disbelief the idea would be that this
is some kind of themed area within an
existing zoo so I wanted to feature a
kind of restaurant have this as an
overlook and resting area next to the
habitat so I wanted to have some
functionality to it as well so I'm just
adding two stalls here for food and
drinks and that's about it supposedly
this whole building would be you know
one big restaurant but I'm not going to
go into interiors for anything
like that because it's quite a closed
building so let's just imagine that a
restaurant would be in the middle of
this when in reality of course within
the game there are just two stalls and
not much else you can really do with it
now it was at this point that I really
wanted to feature some thatched roofs as
well because otherwise I figured it
would be getting quite simple and this
is also where I think the inspiration
from the town of London is becoming very
clear which is a town on the coast of
Kenya which still has a lot of very all
to a hilly architecture looks quite
similar to this I would say or at least
I'm trying to make it look very similar
and also features a lot of these white
walls with thatched roof which are
interesting because these statutes are
never really the same as the gabled
thatched roofs that you can find for
instance in Indonesia or so because they
all have just corners like this like
none of them have actual gable facades
so that's something that I tried to also
copy does make my work a little bit
easier because it means that the
woodwork that I have to do is a lot more
simple although I also have to say
that's a bit of a bummer because I would
love to do a bit more woodwork
one of the coolest things at least in my
opinion that were added in this new dlc
specifically in the south american tank
this is not something that's part of the
free update is bamboo pieces which I'm
also kind of mad about because if you
remember my last video in koalas who I
built this big shrimpanzee lookout
structure out of wooden posts and the
idea was to make it look as much like
bamboo as possible because I wanted to
build a bamboo structure but we didn't
have the pieces back then and now just a
week later well actually maybe like two
weeks later I see that they added those
pieces into the game so I'm kind of
kicking myself because if I would have
waited you know my next turn to build
this structure I would have had the
member pieces by now
but alas anyway I shouldn't complain
about it because these bamboo pieces are
absolutely awesome because not only are
there simple bamboo pieces that aren't
recall
we'll just have a natural bamboo texture
there are also recoverable ones so you
can make these any color you want and
there are thick ones and thin ones so I
use these things more or less throughout
this build to resemble the mangrove
beings beams that you would see in real
life and another really cool part about
them is that they have fitting rope
pieces where it's just a bunch of rope
twisted around the bamboo and it's
something that's not actually within the
bamboo pieces but it's something that
you can separately place on top of them
so you can really create lots of wooden
structures and then put ropes around
them as if you know they aren't nailed
together but they're held together by
ropes which is something that back in
planet coaster I think we always tried
doing with a little hanging rope piece
but that never really you know looks
perfect but these new rope pieces are
super cool and I actually can't wait to
see what people end up doing with them
it's really great for all kinds of
adventurous things or African or
Southeast Asian themes I think another
thing that I think is really cool is for
the new temple pieces that is the the
sort of Aztec like South American temple
pieces there are wall sets but there
aren't any big ruin walls like there
aren't actual wall pieces the only thing
that they provided are big brick pieces
that are off the grid that you can put
together in whatever way you want to
yourself which makes them kind of more
difficult to work with because you can't
just plop down a few walls and call it a
day but they are super versatile so you
can basically make any kind of large
stone brick pattern that you want and I
ended up making this pattern for this
lookout structure on the left side here
where the path pops out a bit you have
this curve going to the the outside into
the inside of what is there going to be
the future habitat for the Lions and for
that one I just wanted to have a
different texture to it than the the
rock cliff that we have next to the
building here
so yeah I really love those pieces as
well it's just the kind of really
versatile thing and also there are
natural non recoverable piece versions
of that but there's also a recoverable
version for every piece in that set so
honestly as much as I've complained in
the past about planet Zoo piece of not
being recolor ball and honestly I
thought the whole rule about you know
natural textures not being recolor ball
because it would look bad I kind of
found that some nonsense because well at
the end of the day I feel like it should
be people's choice whether they want to
recolor something or not I'm super glad
and really just happy overall that we do
have a lot of recallable versions of the
pieces in this pack because it just
makes everything so versatile and I can
see many of these pieces being useful
outside of the context of just a South
American theme now for these bridges I'm
kind of going back to some of the other
pieces but I also use the bamboo pieces
as the railings on the first one because
honestly if you recolor them in in a
dark wooden color you can pretty much
use them for any anything that you need
a narrow piece of wood for so that's why
I ended up that's what I ended up doing
for that bridge and then for the second
bridge just a slightly different kind of
overall design I just ended up adding
some Indian pieces to create the fence
on the side now I'm gonna skip ahead a
little bit here as I just placed down
some foliage around the building to a
section where I'm building a sort of
interior section it's not quite an
interior but this is going to be the
placeholder for what would have been a
real restaurant inside this building but
now it just leads to a few stalls but I
wanted to play a little bit with the
interiors I've seen a bunch of pictures
of Swahili architecture where they have
these large mangrove beams on the beams
on the ceiling and it just looks super
cool and I figured that's something I
wanted to try it's very similar actually
in some ways to some of the ceilings
that you can find and maybe European
Alpine architecture but yeah I'm just
keeping it very simple other than that's
just a few pots and
planters and wall decorations and that's
gonna be it the building is not really
meant to you know look into but just as
to give a general idea that there is
something inside that building now for
this little tower on the side there was
something that I wanted to experiment
with a bit which didn't work out as well
as I'd hoped for this theme but I think
could work out really well with certain
themes and that is using some of these
temple bricks to create brick details on
stucco buildings which especially for
maybe European themes or something like
that would be really cool because these
bricks have just the right size for any
kind of natural stone textures so you
can really blend them into the the
stucco buildings as well and create some
really interesting textures for yourself
these are honestly and I think I've
recently had a conversation with
somebody about this about this these are
honestly the kind of pieces that as a as
a core player if you will of these games
who plays it a lot and just works with
all the pieces a million times these
tiny little objects that seem pretty
redundant in the grand scheme of things
are always the pieces that I look to
look forward to most I think for example
in in planets coaster there were a bunch
of times where a new update would just
bring this very small wooden beam into
the game and you know as a game
developing company I don't think you
expect too much out of those pieces but
in the planet coaster discourse people
would go wild over these little things
because every tiny piece just allows you
to bring so much more texture and detail
into any kind of wall or roof that
you're building and I think a lot of
this goes for the South American pack as
well there's just so many of these new
items they can use that are very
versatile but also just really simple
very small simple pieces that you can
use in different context and especially
because some of them are really
colorable as well are just gonna be so
useful on different themes
now I'm coming to the end of the facade
here and I kind of lose my care for how
this ends up looking because the focus
of this general row of buildings is on
the front which I'd say is by the two
bridges with the tower as well and the
rest kind of curves away from this I
really wanted to create this this sense
also where if you're walking toward this
building it feels like you have a very
very high fov as in a video game like
you're looking through a fisheye lens
because all of the buildings are curving
outward from each other and also moving
down so it really creates the sense of
forced perspective where the building
seems bigger and more impressive than it
really is and you really have to see it
from that particular angle you really
have to see it from the front for this
to work like this row of building looks
significantly worse and kind of terrible
from some other angles so as we get to
the end of this this facade I'm also
going to step down the buildings in
terms of detail and in terms of height
as well so these last few facades aren't
quite as interesting anymore but they're
still really important for finishing you
know the general shape of the building
and also for making this large enough to
realistically believably be some kind of
restaurant building inside a real time
inside a real life suit and now it is a
finally time to get to the actual
habitat I know it took way too long to
actually built this habitat but to be
fair there just isn't that much to it
and I think a lot of the detail and
charm of it really comes from the areas
that the guests are walking around in I
am trying to adhere to some of the basic
rules of well habitat design that I set
for myself or that just kind of exists
in general in a sense that for one I'm
trying to make this of course as natural
as possible and just trying to emulate
the the look of an African grassland but
also for all of the very man-made
architecture that I'm building in this
episode I really want to keep that
strictly for the areas
the guests will be so the shelter for
the Lions is going to be much more
simple and much more natural
just the simple cave structure where it
also connects to the the holding area
behind it and the the staff area where
they could prepare food or care for the
animals so all of that is going to be
much more simple and natural and then
the actual human architecture is only at
the places where people are going to be
walking around now I'm breaking some of
the rules of making habitats here one of
which is to try and create very specific
sight lines where guests don't see other
guests at the end of their viewing
platform because ideally you want to
kind of gaze into an animal's habitat
and not see people behind the animal
that you're looking at and there are a
few sight lines crossing here mostly
just because I've wanted to create the
right sight lines for the buildings as
well so I'm kind of putting the
buildings above animals for that section
there I think the best views of the
habitat would actually be from right
underneath the buildings where you do
look into the animal habitat and in the
backdrop you see the cave with the
shelter so that works much better and
another thing that I'm kind of breaking
is the fact that this habitat does have
some very corner bits where
realistically you want to make sure that
a habitat is built in such a way that
your your animals can walk around it and
especially with big cats that they can
walk around their territory but
especially that nobody can get cornered
because you don't want any animals to be
like socially pushed out from the group
and cornered in any certain space and
especially underneath a bridge I do have
some pretty bad shapes of this habitat
because I think a lion could definitely
be cornered there even though there are
two sides of the pond and they could
walk around it as well it's something
that definitely diminishes the realism
of this habitat so that's a bit
unfortunate honestly I was just so hyped
about this architecture and the new
pieces that I wanted to try that I kind
lost sight of exactly how this exhibit
should realistically be but honestly I
also think at the end of the day it's
not terrible and the Lions in the game
are very happy with it it's just about
the right size and nature wise quite
decent it's just that it's it's
sometimes guilty of doing this thing
where the the human architecture and
sight lines and how the habitat
aesthetically looks is prioritized over
the actual animal welfare because as we
all know animals don't care for how any
of this looks and what's much more
important is just the social dynamics
and how they are cared for and just
their basic needs but then again
architecture and landscaping is kind of
my thing
and if you ask me anything about animals
aside from what is inside the zoo pedia
of planet zoo I'm probably not going to
be able to give the best answers anyway
so you just gonna have to forgive me for
that these are my freak misses and
strengths personally but all together
I'm still really happy with how this
came out I think it's a decent showcase
also of what the new pieces in the DLC
can do because they can do so much more
than just South American architecture
and I'm really happy about that
so yeah I'm gonna share with you some
cinematic shots and leave it at that
hopefully I'll see you in the next
episode of whatever random habitat it is
or perhaps even in komali Zoo because it
is my turn this week so we'll see how
that goes
bye everybody and stay safe stay at home
and let's just keep playing video games
right
I don't know personally I'm really glad
to have this hobby because it's
definitely something that in
self-isolation it still works really
well and it's just fun to be part of
this online community and share stuff
around you know so let's just keep doing
that anyway I'll see myself out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]